[Music]
hey i'm out for you joshua
hey what's up i'm israel addison here
and we're going to be on this week's
episode of true for dab
check it out
[Music]
hey what's going on everybody for first
week feast i'm shawn evans and welcome
back to another episode of truth or dab
the hot one special where we give our
guests two simple options
tell the truth or suffer the wrath of
the last dab and today we're joined by
two of the baddest men on the planet in
israel adesanya and anthony joshua izzy
is the ufc middleweight champion one of
the cover athletes of the new ea sports
ufc 4
and has a fight against paulo costa on
september 26th
anthony joshua is a two-time unified
heavyweight champion boxer
also a playable character in the game
but how will they fare going round for
round against the last dab i guess we'll
find out today
anthony izzy welcome to the show hey
thanks for having us
thanks for having us anthony we'll start
with you
i'm curious your thoughts on youtube
personalities orchestrating boxing
matches with multi-million dollar
payouts
what's something that excites you about
this recent trend of internet clout
monsters stepping into the ring
and then what about it all do you find
most embarrassing
what excites me the most is the fact
that it's bringing a whole new audience
to the fight game
i think that's important so i'm happy
that they're doing it
and the thing that annoys me the most is
there's so much talent from the
grassroots level that are trying to get
their
you know their name recognized by the
bigger audience
and they're struggling so it's a world
of who's popular and who can just do it
versus
who's talented and who's trying to get
their name recognized but isn't getting
a look in so
it's a catch-22 but the big benefit is
more eyes on a sport will give the
grassroot talent
more opportunity to expose themselves to
a new audience
well said all right izzy the spotlight
is on you now
i know that you're a fierce fighter a
competitor but also very confident
professional
if you were in charge of the ufc what's
one rule change
and one operational change that you
would make on your first day in office
oh man there's so there's a few there's
a few but um
a stupid one admit a stupid one i'm
gonna answer this twice the stupid one
is the 12 to six elbow
because that is just so old you can't
elbow this way you have to have it on an
angle i feel like
if i'm throwing my shin at your face
this
is pretty it's pretty alright it's
pretty easy but um apart from that i'd
add more weight classes
between the middleweight and light
heavyweight between the welterweights
and middleweights uh amongst the bigger
weight classes because it starts to get
a little bit wider the gap
so that and the dumbass 12 to 6 elbow
room
yeah all right through the first round
so far no
wings but we'll turn up the heat a
little bit more here in the second round
and izzy will stay with you ufc fighters
seem to be in a constant state of
conflict with the media that surrounds
the sport
who is the reporter or outlet that you
think covers you most
unfairly and why see i'd love to answer
that one but i blocked them
in my in real life you know like that
episode of black mirror where you kind
of like blocks on and they just became a
blur
i've done that to a couple of reporters
and i can't remember their name
but i know their faces and if i did
remember the name i'd say
i think that's a dab i think that's a
dab
all right wait how do we hit that the
first one this is the first one right
yep i like what he was doing there can't
remember the name if not i put them on
blast right now i swear to god
you know me i don't pull no plugs just
so you guys can see it hold up
so you know i'm not cheating oh there we
go
just a little dab just a dab you ready
i'm picking the same wing up the same
way
pray for me chest
there we go that smells spicy that
smells
very earthy
[Music]
all right let's go
[Music]
oh so far so good
i feel like i picked the first one the
right one because that
definitely might be the hardest one and
izzy i know you're tough
but another thing to think about is
sometimes these things grow they kind of
plume
a little bit oh no i know we're from
nigeria we understand spices
so i know this is this level one but
then between level one there's level 1.5
and i can feel it on my lips right now
tantalizing if you will
i beg now so anthony you've had a
dominating career
23 and 1 professional record including
21 knockouts
thinking back on your career which
includes four fights that ended in the
first round
which opponent would you say was your
easiest win
i would say emmanuelli leo so i've come
to the ring now
straight after the olympics i'm fresh
from my amateur career
he was uh eight fights in eight wins
this is my professional debut and i went
in there and hit him with uh like i
would call it the george foreman because
it was just swinging from the hips
woman i hit him with the last one bang
lights out
ko pro debut go well and it's the start
of the professional career
there it is all right we are through
three rounds
lots of truth here and truth or dab to
start things off
anthony you're a champion boxer an
olympic gold medalist
but beneath that chiseled veneer i know
that the man who was awarded the most
excellent order of the british empire by
the queen herself has a softer side
what's the last movie that made you
did you want to try this yeah
if you're asking yeah i do
all right it's not that bad the first
one's not that bad but it smells bad
you'll be all right
it's something i've already got
something in here i've already got just
so you know i'm not cheating
just try just just try even just the
skin just the skin it's not that bad it
actually tastes quite good
there you can see here add it in there
[Music]
[Laughter]
that's good that's all that's easy yeah
i promise you it's not that bad you're
good
is that i lost you'll be right he's
right i don't hate this much i
i ate this much you'll be right
light work light work
it's just like chicken sour that's like
chicken
this one ain't too bad this one's not so
bad exactly i'm telling you
just like a dipping sauce so this one i
would say
is suitable for family functions
barbecues christmas dinners
this one is acceptable in the household
izzy
what is dana white's most annoying habit
that people who don't work with him
close like you do might not know about
i'd say it's what makes him great but
also what makes him
susceptible he's very emotional i'd say
in business sometimes he gets very
emotional but
that's also what put the ufc on the map
to where it is today
but i'd say he's very emotional that's
hindered him a couple of times in the
past
going into the last round here already
already
already touched the middle sauce all
right izzy
eye gouges greasing blows below the belt
they're all a stain on this great sport
we know as mixed martial arts
who in your opinion though is the
dirtiest fighter in the sport
oh the dirtiest fighter in the sport
there's a few but even the guy i'm
fighting next
like i said i'm gonna pop him before
usada does
but he has definitely got some extra
supplements south of the border that he
takes
and he even came out saying that he
hasn't been tested which i don't
i don't believe i believe they test i
just got tested last night how about
that right chance
exactly i just got tested last night i
don't understand
the stress it takes to cheat that's for
me but you know what i just feel like
trying this one anyway so i might try a
little bit
on one of these chicken wings just to
see we can't just go through the whole
thing with only trying one sauce
we gotta break at least two at least two
well this this first one still
still tingling my tongue and my lips i'm
tantalizing my guys
in my mouth
it takes about probably 10 minutes and
it's already gone this one let me see
i'll just do a little
coat you ready we're ready
all right
wow it jumps off the left oh my god my
guy i beg
it jumps up in levels yeah that's like
if this is level three this is level six
all i did was lick my finger and i saw
what you did
let me just try it let me just try a bit
before i bite this whole chicken
oh man
it's still kicking that is a big jump in
levels this like you said family
functions all that
yes you hate someone if you hate someone
this is easily something you can put in
your food
god damn i'll try a little bite though
cause i know [ __ ]
[Music]
okay with the meat it's all right but
that first kick though that's what it's
going to kick in it's going to kick in
a slow burner all right anthony last
question we talked about boxers fighting
outside the rules but i'm curious
can you name a fighter or promoter who
you suspect
has been involved in actually fixing a
boxing match
spill the tea and this
this isn't current promoters i'm taking
you back right
and don king oh that's the easy answer i
want the teaser
it's still current though but the t i
don't believe anyone's doing that
anymore
but years ago the mafia was involved in
boxing
there was a lot of um organizations that
was involved in boxing instead of
developing sport
um so there was a lot of interesting
business going on now this sport's
very clean it's a very well structured
organization i don't think any
any corrupt units happen well there you
have it another truth or dab is in the
books make sure to pick up your copy of
ea sports ufc
4 available now and check out izzy
taking on paulo costa
on september 26th guys thank you so much
a lot of truth a little bit of dab had a
lot of fun doing this look it
from from new zealand from england here
in new york
all over the time zones truth or dab
until next time
everybody just be careful around your
eyes
[Music]
you want to try one jim if his boy tries
well you got to try the first one
come sit down come sit down with me bro
hey come here come here come here pull
up
bring your chair bring it here bring
your chair we're all going to go in
there
i love this we've got a vegan here as
well
i can't buy it's going to ruin my day
[Laughter]
i got to go to sleep after this you're
not sleeping
dog welcome the next two hours all right
you ready
triple x izzy are you doing it are you
doing it if you do it i'll do it
yeah come on we are we're from ogun
states
now i'm gonna
he's a vegan so there's no chicken he's
just doing it from the spoon he's a
vegan
no where's hey respect broth all right
one
two three let's go
[Laughter]
do you know what it is as you're
answering the questions
yeah it starts playing in the back of
your mind
yeah it's starting to keep your mouth
moving as well if you keep your mouth
moving it kind of helps
like yeah yeah it just slowly comes try
this one as well
after you hear that there you go
on the lips on the lips yeah it kicks
you on the lips right away
oh champ good luck
[Laughter]
all right brother see you guys thank you
hey what's going on hot ones fans this
is shawn evans checking in with a very
exciting announcement
hot ones truth or dab the game is
finally here baby
what's in the box what's in the box
what's in the box
well the kit comes complete with 250
question cards
and then here's how the game works you
just go around the table
you take turns being the host being the
players
and when you're a player you get asked a
question you have a choice
just like in the show answer it honestly
or suffer the wrath of the last dab and
take a look at this
there's even a mini bottle of the last
dab included i suggest you have napkins
on hand
you have to have some milk on hand and
of course be careful be very careful
around the eyes
hot ones truth or dab the play at home
game is available at shop.firstwe
fees.com
and heatness.com play at your own risk
wings not included
[Music]
you